تفاعل مع قصه التعرف ولي عهد الاردن على
خطيبته رجوى بعد السقوط شيرين تعود لبيتها
الكبير انفصال تامر حسني وبسمه بوسيل
واليسا تدعو جمهورها للتفهم اليكم الابرز
في اسبوع
[موسيقى]
مع اقتراب موعد زفافه كشف ولي عهد الاردن
الامير الحسين بن عبد الله الثاني عن
الطريقه التي تعرف فيها على خطيبته
السعوديه رجوى ال سيت وذلك ردا على سؤال
احد المشاركين في جلسه حواريه لولي العهد
ضمن منتدى تواصل الذي نظم مؤخرا في
العاصمه الاردنيه عمان الحمد لله قصه
بسيطه يعني انا كان عندي زميله في المدرسه
صاحبه رجوى
وتعرفت على رضوى من خلالها يعني وعلى فكره
على فكره ما حكينا او شفنا بعض لفتره بعد
ما تعرفنا وكان في يوم هيك اشي يذكرني
فيها وقررت اسال عنها سبحان الله صار نصيب
وتم تداول الفيديو الاميره على نطاق واسع
وحقق تفاعلا على منصات التواصل الاسبوع
الماضي انا بعتبر حالي محظوظ لانه مش كل
يوم الواحد تعرف على حدا زي رجل
ومما تفاعل معه المتابعون على نطاق واسع
ايضا حادثه سقوط المطربه المصريه شيرين
عبد الوهاب على المسرح في حفلها بدبي
والذي اتى بعد ترقب كبير ووعدت شيرين في
بدايته بانها لن تغيب عن جمهورها ابدا
وهذا ما سيحدث بالفعل حيث اعلن تقويم
الرياض عن مشاركتها في ليله روائع الموجي
تكريما لذكرى الموسيقار المصريه الراحل
محمد الموجي في الرابع من مايو ايار
المقبل وياتي هذا الاعلام بالتزامن مع ما
اعلنته شركه روتانا عن عوده شيرين لبيتها
الكبير وحفله في جده وليلى كبرى في موسم
الرياض بعنوان صوت احساس العرب وذلك بعد
الصلح في اعقاب النزاع القضائي الاخير بين
الشركه والمطربه المصريه
[موسيقى]
تفاصيل صغيره لكن مهمه حالت دون توقيع عقد
الالبوم المنتظر لاليسا مع روتانا بحسب ما
اعلنت المغنيه اللبنانيه عبر حساباتها
الرسميه على مواقع التواصل وكشفت عن
اختلاف وجهات النظر لكنها اكدت بالمقابل
على متانت علاقتها مع الشركه التي تعتبرها
عائلتها ودعت جمهورها الى التفاهم قائله
كل تاخيره وفيها خيره
[موسيقى]
ومن الاخبار التي حققت تفاعلا كبيرا على
منصات التواصل الاسبوع الماضي خبر انفصال
الفنان المصري تامر حسني عن بسمه بوسيل
والذي اعلنته الاخيره عبر خاصيه القصص في
حسابها على انستجرام واكده تامر بمشاركه
القصه والتعليق عليها عشره 12 عام مش هينه
ربنا يكتب لك ويكتب لي كل الخير يا بسوم
ساظل الاب والاخ والصديق والسند في حفظ
الله
اخيرا وردنا على الجدل الذي اثاره الفيلم
المرتقب الذي ستعرضه منصه نتفليكس عن
الملكه كليوباترا اعلنت قناه الوثائقيه
المصريه بدء التحضيرات مع عدد من
المتخصصين في التاريخ والاثار
والانثروبولوجي لانتاج وثائقي عن هذه
الملكه التي اعتبرت اخر ملوك الاسره
البطلميه التي حكمت مصر في عقاب وفاه
الاسكندر الاكبر